Hey, David.
At what point would a military coup to remove
Trump not be the absolute worst option?
I'm really only half joking.
So I think we have to be very careful about
these questions.
Donald, I get why people are sort of worried
and tense about this.
Donald Trump has floated the idea of delaying
the election.
He's talked about it's going to be rigged.
He almost certainly will claim some aspect
of it is rigged.
He still hasn't even accepted the popular
vote results of 2016, which is an election
he won.
You can be sure that he is going to find something
to take issue with in November.
And certainly if he loses, he absolutely is
going to.
I don't think it's going to come to anything
like a military coup.
I, I.
Most people in the audience seem to be on
board with me.
And on the same page that January 20th, Trump,
if he loses or there is no election, he is
no longer the president.
And it's on the one hand, not going to require
a military coup to remove Donald Trump.
But on the other hand, I think that he's going
to go.
I think he he you know, Sam Ceder earlier
this week talked about lawsuits and lawsuits
maybe going all the way up to the Supreme
Court.
I don't think that that's totally implausible.
And that's certainly a reason for us to try
to run up the score and have a huge popular
vote victory.
First step is not to lose in the popular vote.
Next step is to have a big popular vote, big
victory, which hopefully will translate into
an Electoral College victory.
But we know the tricks that they're planning.
There's foreign meddling going on again.
Postmaster is trying to kneecap and cripple
the post office.
They're trying to prevent mail in voting.
And they're suing states in order to try to
do it.
They're deregistering voters.
They're trying to close polling place.
We know all the tactics.
The experts have looked at it.
And here's the bottom line.
All of these things can certainly have an
effect on the results.
If everybody goes out and votes, we overwhelm
it.
All of these techniques only work when half
the country doesn't vote.
If we actually get the vote out, these questions
of the military removing Trump or whatever,
they instantly become moot.
They really do.
So I think that would I would encourage the
audience to do.
Is trust that the best remedy?
Is for all of us to vote.
All of these probably will Trump leave or
not?
Will we need the military to remove him?
An overwhelming defeat of Donald Trump in
both the popular and electoral votes is going
to prevent all of these issues if it's overwhelming.
Even this Supreme Court with two of Donald
Trump's selections, Neil Gorsuch and Brett
Kavanaugh, is not going to do anything that
that would somehow allow Trump to stay in
power.
The best remedy is every single person voting.